what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar today we are going to be going
over every sins backstory a good story
is vital for a character and the seven
deadly sins series has some of the best
backstories I've come across so I'm
extremely excited about this video
especially with the new simulation
season now airing if you're hyper than
you see some AI want to see more seven
deadly sins videos on this channel make
sure to smash that like button to let me
know if you haven't be sure to subscribe
and ring that notification bell so you
actually get notified when new seven
deadly sins videos come out also follow
us on Twitter and Instagram and and me
uproar for more content and crucial
updates like information about new
trailers and new seasons on the day dis
video is released I will be conducting a
tournament bracket via Instagram stories
for which sins backstory is the best you
can vote on instagram @ and me out
drawer link in the description if you're
not watching within the first 24 hours
never fear I will have more tournament
brackets like these in the future
so make sure you're following us on
instagram at anime up drawer link in the
description anyways there will be some
manga spoilers in this video about the
secret paths of the sins you've been
warned and now without further ado let's
jump into it this is gonna be in random
order so I might as well start with bond
one of my favorite characters in all of
anime sponsor now the poor kid web
crappy parents at best they ignored him
and at worst they beat him really bad
they sent him out to steal for them and
would even beat him if they thought he
kept the food he stole for himself so
not only that his parents not provide
for him bond was forced to feed them
bond even had a fear of falling asleep
as a kid because his dad would kick him
in the stomach if he saw him sleeping
and not stealing
he gets so hungry sometimes that he
would even eat his own puke one of the
saving graces of bonds life was his kind
little sister who used to follow him
around everywhere he went but at the age
of four she died from starvation
so yeah saying that bonds upbringing was
tough is an understatement for most of
us bond stories should put our own
challenges into perspective nobody's
life is perfect but chances are your
parents didn't beat you when you tried
to fall asleep and you didn't have to
watch the only person you loved starve
to death at a young age
however bonds life began to turn around
when she vago entered the picture
he was the good father figure that bond
never had they met in prison of all
places
Javad will offered bond food this was
already weird because most people just
try to take things from him without ever
giving anything in return
then Siobhan go help bond escape from
the prison and took him to his hideout
where he gave him even more food later
bond got tricked and kidnapped he was
going to be delivered to some crazy
aristocrat who loves to torture kids we
never actually met this aristocrat as
far as I know all we got was this
passing reference but if you stop and
reflect for a second you'll realize how
unbelievably messed up the world bond
grew up in was it's a world where
someone who was known to do such
horrendous things not only gets away
with it
what has people eager to help him get
more victims luckily Zhivago happened to
be robbing the guys that kidnapped bond
and managed to accidentally save bond in
the process again he fed bond then bond
asked him to teach him how to steal
since he had to steal anyway he might as
well get good at it since he was just
getting caught and beaten up over and
over again at the time now I want to say
that the moments between bond and
survive are definitely some of the most
touching in the entire series and we get
one after Shyvana agrees to teach bond
to steal bond is nodding off but he
reveals that he doesn't want to fall
asleep because as mentioned his old man
will kick him in the stomach
however Chuvalo says he'll watch over
bond and lets him rest on his lap bond
has a good sleep for probably the first
time in his life and it's even more
heartwarming when you consider that
Javon just has to chill there sitting
because if he moves he might wake up
bond it's like when you go out of your
way to rest in an uncomfortable position
because your pet is resting on you and
it looks comfortable so you don't want
to disturb it this whole time survival
has been going out of his way to help
bond and it's all the more impactful
because of the stark contrast between
his selfless behavior and bonds real
fathers deeply flawed and selfish
behavior we get some funny panels in the
manga boninger boggles stealing together
bond gets caught and we see Joe Vogel
humorously rescuing him carrying him
over his shoulders she boggle at this
point also tells bond about the Fountain
of Youth in the fairy Kings forest as if
he didn't Oh Siobhan you enough it's
interesting to think that bond might
have never met the love his life Alaine
if not for Siobhan telling him
about the Fountain of Youth and the
fairy Kings forest later bond and
Chicago are talking about survivals
other son Sally on bond looks a bit
embarrassed and jealous until Zhivago
tells him he also has a kid who looks
and sounds rough and standoffish named
bond
I am literally not lying when I say that
just revisiting this part in the manga
got my eyes to water as I'm writing this
this part is just so touching after
hearing that Chicago views him as a son
bonds face goes red and he shyly looks
down it's the nicest thing anyone has
ever said to him and it's music to his
ears
Shiva tells baa never to trust anyone
but bond says he trusts Chicago and
Zhivago can't help but hug the boy then
he shoves his head in a playful way and
tells him to get some sleep because
their thieving early in the morning the
next morning bond can't help but smile
he's so happy that he finally has a
father who cares about him since Siobhan
goes late bond decides that he'll go
ahead and rob the house on his own so
that Zhivago will be surprised and
praise him however he gets caught and
beaten up it turns out that Shivaji was
late because he overslept then as he's
rushing to get to bond he finds out that
his werefox son in the mountains has
been discovered
you see Shivaji was aware Fox this whole
time he sees bond getting beaten up and
it's excruciating seeing the look on his
tortured face as he tries to decide
which one of his sons to go help then he
turns into his werefox form and with
tears in his eyes apologizes to bond as
he turns and goes to rescue his
biological son as he's running tears are
streaming down his face and bonds words
ring through his head
I trust you Siobhan go and quote
survival considers himself to be a
despicable man for abandoning bond in
the end he was too late to save his
biological son's life too he was too
scared to return to the village because
he was afraid to learn that bond had
been killed too
although zhivago didn't come back bond
survived and never bore a grudge against
him he always thought of him as the best
father he could have asked for later a
23 year old bond remember zhivago story
and visits the fairy Kings forests in
order to steal the Fountain of Youth
bonds life wasn't that good up to this
point so he thought that if he gained
immortality something good would
eventually happen to him
a hopeful yet somehow depressing thought
bond keeps trying to get to the Fountain
of Youth but Elaine the fairy who
protects the fountain keeps sending him
flying away
Team Rocket style eventually the
persistent bond uses his three section
staff to bring the cup to him but before
he can drink it Elaine uses tree
branches to restrain him Elaine explains
the bond that without the found of youth
the entire forest would wither away bond
says he's got it he won't try to steal
it anymore
Elaine doesn't trust on a selfish human
would give up so easily so she reads his
mind and realizes that he's telling the
truth
Elaine explains to bond that she's been
watching the forest in place of her
absent fairy King brother for 700 years
and nothing good happened all that time
thus bond can't even be sure that
something good will happen to him if he
lives for eternity wow that's harsh
luckily though the good thing that they
were both waiting for is actually their
meeting they quickly take a liking to
each other they talk and Elaine starts
to feel sad at the thought that bond
will leave her she says to herself and I
quote I wish bond didn't come here to
steal the Fountain of Youth but instead
came for me
bond is actually nearby and overhears
her he responds then how about I do that
and quote bond has also developed
feelings for Elaine as she explains he
doesn't get along well with other folks
and she actually took the time to listen
to him bond promises to bring her
brother back and free her from her
lonely guardian duties then Elaine hugs
bond only the second time we've seen him
hugged by someone however this side
story doesn't have such a happy ending a
red demon attacks the forest bond takes
his heart out with his snatch ability
and thinks he's killed it but demons
actually have multiple hearts all he did
was attracted demons attention then the
red demon shoots lasers out of his eyes
and gives both bond and Elaine mortal
wounds Elaine tries to give bond the
found of youth so that he can survive
but he insists that she drinking Elaine
seems to drink it but then kiss his bond
and in this way passes the fluid into
his mouth definitely one of the most
epic kisses ever bond with his newfound
immortal powers kills the red demon then
Elaine dies in his arms she died in part
because he was there and attracted the
red demons attention to them so bond
can't help but blame himself for her
death he considers it a
that is too great to ever atone for but
still he swears to Elaine that he will
steal her away one day it'll just be
from the world of the dead rather than
from the fairy Kings Forest bond goes on
to replant the fairy Kings forest
elsewhere for Elaine and the fairy star
referring to this human as the new fairy
King he occasionally comes to give his
blood to the forest so that the Fountain
of Youth inside him can keep the forest
healthy as the authorities usually do
they get things extremely mixed up they
blame bond for killing Elaine in order
to satisfy his own greed for immortality
bond who does blame himself for Elaine's
death doesn't try to clear up the
misunderstanding he now wants to be
punished he wants to feel physical pain
and torture because that might take
attention away from the emotional
anguish he's experiencing they tried to
execute bond a total of 33 times but
they obviously never succeed because
he's immortal you had to respect their
persistence though you'd think that
they'd give up after the first or second
time had no effect about four years
later Mele Otis comes to get ba out of
prison bond who has no idea who Mellie
Otis is reveals that he is imprisoned on
purpose however Mele oldest uses force
to get him to come out and bond gets
excited by Mele Otis's power he decides
to tag along so he can continue to fight
the captain about a year later bond goes
through a phase of stealing stuffed
animals from the children of the kingdom
King is furious and returns them all and
starts the follow bought all the time to
ensure that he doesn't do something like
that again although they mess with each
other it's clear that these two make a
good team
and at this time bond has no idea that
King is a lean sister and King has no
idea that bond was there when his sister
died at some point bond is messing
around and tries to steal Mellie Otis's
sword the captain is not having it
though and gives bond the wound on his
neck and face that never heals it's the
only scar he has on his immortal
regenerating body ten years before the
main story takes place the seven deadly
sins are framed for Alice's death and on
the captain's orders they disperse after
not hearing from ilioneus for a while
bond hears rumors that he's dead as he
did upon Elaine's that he intentionally
Lots himself be imprisoned it is during
this capture that he loses his sacred
treasure his reason for going to prison
is that he wants to feel pain that can
make him feel alive again he's been
through so much pain at
losing Zhivago Elaine and Mellie Otis
that he's become numb to almost
everything while he's in prison he
breaks out every so often to give his
blood to the fairy Kings Forrest and
then comes back to be tortured some more
and this is what his existence is until
he's introduced into the main story
it appears that unbearable emotional
anguish turned him into the masochist we
know today next let's look at go Thurs
backstory
Gotha is a doll created by the demon
Gotha who used to be the commandant of
selflessness over three thousand years
ago he created go Thurs so that he could
experience the outside world through the
doll from demon prison however dog
author also has a Pinocchio mode where
he can also function as his own person
just like Pinocchio the demon go third
loves his doll as if he was his own
biological child the doll was even made
in the image of his old lover let the
demon change the sex of the doll so that
he wouldn't get any impure thoughts the
demon go through uses the dog othor in
order to help him break out of prison
then he has the doll help him cast the
most powerful of genjutsu they make
everyone believe that the Archangel
Miele is actually the demon esta rosa
and in this way they put a temporary
stop to the holy war the demon Gotha
uses all of his power to cast this
forbidden spell and as a result he dies
in front of his doll he asked the go
third doll to realize a dream he cannot
which may be in part to establish a
lasting and just peace in the world the
goal third doll who will just call go
through from now on disappears and fraud
retakes his place as the commandment of
selflessness
fast forward to some decades before the
main story go through who's lost his
memories is found by a 16 year old
princess Nadja Leonys the older sister
of the current king Bartra i warn you
that go thirst Ori is one of the saddest
and that's saying a lot when you're
talking about the seven deadly sins
Nadja and go through get to know each
other and start falling in love Gotha
eventually comes across as creator's
chair and cries even though Naja wants
to go there doesn't want not just to
give him a gift because he thinks that
if she does she'll disappear like his
creator
however Naja promises him that won't
happen and gives him a book to read
books are a thing that connects the two
Naja was never very strong and could
never leave the castle so a lot of her
time was filled with reading books she
loves books gopher finishes the book she
gave him in moments she thinks he's
lying but he quotes specific chapters
and even changes his hair to look more
like one of the characters
fYI as a doll he can change a shape
length and color of his hair he can also
open up his chest and show people the
magic heart that his creator gave him as
a gift this gift is supposedly imbued
with the magic of the heart he shows his
heart - Naja
and Naja faints Goethe her helps her get
to her room when she wakes up even
though she knows go through as a doll
she can't help but think how in love
with him she is she's so taken by him
that it scares her he kid Bartra smiles
upon hearing this then go there in a
maid out that appears and Naja's
embarrassed that he heard her Bartra
explains that Gotha is dressed as a maid
because that's the only way he wouldn't
attract suspicion for being in the
princess's room so this is actually the
origin of how both are began dressing in
girls clothes
anyways Goethe is happy that Naja
doesn't hate him for making her faint he
hugs her and he says that he would be
lonely and sad if she left him so yes
even though he's a doll Goethe her can
in fact feel emotions as his tears along
with his feelings of happiness
loneliness and sadness illustrate go
thir continues to dress as a maid and
stays close to the weak and sickly yet
happy Naja even other people around the
castle like her brothers can't help but
notice that she is awfully cheery since
she started spending time with Goethe er
they do romantic stuff like dance and
ride on horseback together
it is beautiful watching how selfless go
there is he does everything including
him personate the fictional character
that Nigel loves in order to make her
happy and even though she'd love Goethe
her no matter what form he takes she
greatly appreciates his efforts to make
her happy
alas though the happily ever after
ending was not to be goal her was an
immortal doll and Naja was a sickly
often bedridden human not just starts
getting sicker
although Gotha thinks he's just an empty
doll now I just sure's him that what's
inside her and inside go through will
never change they share the same heart
Colter is inexpressibly sad and asks
Naja if she's going away he says her
heartbeat has been getting weaker by the
day the two start kissing take off their
clothes and you can imagine what they
start doing from there
so yes to me it seems pretty clear dye
go through the doll can in fact do that
Naja eventually dies with a smile on her
face but not before revealing that go
thir made her dream come true her dream
was to spend her last days on earth with
Goethe er when go through senses that
her heart has stopped beating he freaks
out he doesn't want her to die he
remembers what she said about them
having the same heart and he takes out
his own he doesn't care what happens to
him but if his heart will help Nigel
live he is willing to give it to her of
course go Thurs extremely sad and
sweetly naive attempt to bring Naja back
fails the authorities come in and to
them it looks like go through has
deflowered and murdered the princess as
a result he gets arrested for his
supposed sin of lust like bond go
through experiences unbearable heartache
after his lover's death so he decides to
get rid of his heart and erase his
memories he thinks if a heart can hurt
so much then he wants to be nothing more
than a doll go there stories especially
touching because he is so naive
he is so innocent and selfless that
watching him fall in love only to lose
it is so sad we can't help but feel
sorry for this doll who clearly feels as
much as any man could time passes on and
even though he erases memories and
supposedly gave up his magic heart go
Thurs heart continues to show itself in
a variety of ways for instance some time
after the sins were framed Goethe I ran
into a monster instead of killing him he
tried to help it by giving him his
Armour then he was for the most part
nice to a young boy called Pelle Oh
after the boy helped him out he looked
after the young boy until the sense came
to get him and he was so nice to him
that the boy cries when Goethe her has
to leave he even copied the boys late
mother's hairstyle and a traveling
entertainer speech and behavior in order
to make the boy happy for as long as he
could like the Tin Man In The Wizard of
Oz Goethe her had a heart all along even
if it doesn't always seem like it next
we're going to be looking at Merlin
retaining a strongest wizard compared to
the Merlin from Arthurian legend naka
Mizuki's version of Merlin looks like a
hot 30 year old woman most of the time
and I'm probably not the only one who
appreciates that change Merlin was
always surrounded by a lot of mystery so
her backstory was especially interesting
to learn of
like go thir Merlin was around 3,000
years ago Merlin was from the city of
beli a Llewyn belly a Llewyn was the
capital of the Wizards her father was
the elder sage and chief of the capital
since Merlin was born with the amazing
magic of infinity everyone wanted her to
be on their side the Wizards of beli
Allen wanted her all to themselves as in
the demon king and the supreme deity
against the wishes of the Wizards she
negotiated with the demon king and the
supreme deity she tricked both of them
into giving her amazing gifts by saying
she would join them the demon king gave
her detailed information on all the
secret arts and mysteries of the
underworld and divine protection that
could defend against the brainwashing of
the goddesses and the supreme deity
bestowed the child divine protection
able to nullify any and all manner of
dark curses and commandments then after
she got the gifts she disappeared having
the seed to gods as revenge the supreme
deity and demon king worked together to
utterly destroy the city of beli
alloweth they rain destruction down for
1,000 days poor wizards of beli Alwyn
they had nothing to do with the
deception they even asked Merlin not to
meet with either God and then they got
punished even though Merlin wasn't even
in the city at the time so in this way
you could say that Merlin was a glutton
for knowledge and power since she was
willing to sacrifice her entire city in
order to acquire those things
Merlin also knew meliodas and the
goddess Elisabeth three thousand years
ago she viewed Elisabeth as her big sis
Merlin was one of the first two members
of the seven deadly sins and she held
meli onus find the other five members 16
years before the main story takes place
Merlin was also one of the first people
to take interest in esken oars monstrous
strength while most people just feared
it as a result
ESCA noir was extremely grateful and
even fell in love with Merlin at some
point she created eScan oars glasses
that can keep him from transforming in
the daytime and she also created the
enchanted armor that go through use to
move around it she even had time to
support King Arthur teach Vivian the
ways of magic and seal away part of
Melly Otis's power among other things
she's always been extremely impressive
and busy mage next let's take a look at
the giant earth bender Dee and herself
although she's approximately 750 years
old she's actually one of the youngers
700 years ago at the age of 50 which is
very young in giant years the N left a
giant clan because she hated fighting so
much she gets so lonely that she creates
two golems out of stone using
earthbending to keep her company
then she eventually runs into Harlequin
whose memories have been erased so he
doesn't know that he should be getting
back to the fairy Kings forest since
he's the king at all
props to Harlequin for being able to be
a king without ever being in his own
realm anyway since neither of them
supposedly have anywhere to go they get
to know each other and become really
good friends they spent a lot of time
together many human lifetimes and
eventually the n gets sick fun fact
fairies don't get sick so King is very
worried about the end since he's got no
idea how to heal her he decides that he
needs to go get the n medicinal herbs
but the N holds him and won't let him go
she doesn't want to be by herself so she
asks him to stay with her a human comes
along and helps her out and king who
mistrust humans thanks him a bit
reluctantly the old man's medicine works
and the N gets better King in the end
continued to play and one day the N rips
her clothes so King makes her some new
ones the a man can go to help the old
man that helped them once but he's dead
and even his grandchild has grown old
and has kids of his own this is when
King and the N realized that what feels
like the other day to them feels like
forever ago to humans it is around this
time that the N learns about the human
concept of marriage
it makes the Angelus and she asks King
if he loves her with a red face he says
he does then Dee Ann asks King to never
stop loving her and he promises that he
will always love her and stay by her
side she replies all she needs is for
him to love her which is good because
King is about to leave he soon sees a
cart that reminds him of his past and he
remembers everything he remembers that
he is the fairy king he sees that there
is trouble over at the human village and
he goes to help the Ann tells him to
find their friends and bring them back
safely
King promises to come back to her and
the N cries tears of joy King finds out
that the person attacking the village is
none other than his best fairy friend
halgrim who was getting revenge on the
humans King stops him and decides he
needs to atone for his sin
in order to do this he decides that he
needs to leave the an even though he
loves her he erases her memories of him
so she doesn't miss him before letting
himself get arrested
Deann returns to the giant Klan after
that about 16 years before the main
story takes place Deann is fighting
alongside the giant leader Matrona and
her friend Dolores the Giants are hard
as mercenaries by humans it's the way
they make their money but Rona gets mad
at both Dolores and the an after one
battle because the lure is defeated no
humans and the end defeated about ten
but didn't kill them Matrona tells them
that the Giants are proud warriors it is
a Giants duty to seek out combat it is a
Giants dream to die in battle
it is a Giants nature to find life in
war to kill an opponent is the greatest
honor a giant can ask for like Dee and
Delores hates fighting and she'd rather
die than have to fight Dolores is
constantly falling behind the more
gifted the Anne Matrona thinks that she
could eventually turn the Anne into the
strongest fighter the giant clan has
ever seen but the Anne hates the way
Matrona thinks and behaves the N decides
to leave the clan again and invites the
loris but Dolores changed her mind about
leaving
she says that no place would accept
giants so Diane leaves on her own humans
start to bug Deanna and Mellie Otis
steps in before she can respond he kicks
their butts and insults them for ganging
up on a little girl Mellie Otis treats
the end like an actual girl rather than
like a scary giant and this is why the
end gets a crush on him
keep in mind her memories of King who
she loved have been erased
Mellie Otis and Deanne hang out a bit
eat some food and part ways
DeeAnn after meeting Mellie Otis Vasa go
tell Dolores that she's found a place
that will accept them however her best
friend is dead
while Deanna was away she was sent to
serve as a guard for a mining town she
was killed by some mountain bandits
Deanne punches Matrona in the face for
sending Dolores to her death which one
hits her back and tells her that they
had to participate in a wide-scale
suppression of the savages with the
Leonys Knights tomorrow at this point
the and decides that she doesn't want to
be like Matrona who glorifies fighting
or like Dolores who would rather die
than fight dn will fight if she has to
but only to protect someone she cares
about Deanne keeps having flashbacks of
King but she still can't remember him
clearly the men
Marie's are all fuzzy she starts to
confuse the words that King spoke in the
past with Mellie Otis who was recently
nice to her and that is why she develops
feelings for him it is mainly because
she is projecting her feelings for King
onto Mellie Otis dee Ann not super happy
about it comes the next morning to help
the Giant clan and the Knights of Leonys
however it was all a trap that was set
by the Knights of leiana's to take out
Matrona the out-of-control thing of the
land they begin to fight a Matrona ends
up protecting the end from a poison
arrow showing that she is in fact a
caring person it turns out that the ants
parents asked Patrona to raise her to be
strong like her own little sister so
that the ant could survive on her own
and that is exactly what Moroni was
trying to do all these years as Matrona
is succumbing to the poison she wishes
that she could think of something else
to say but she can't because all she
knows is how to fight and with that she
appears to pass away however she ends up
having enough power to use one more
amazing earthbending attack that creates
countless spikes that impale about 330
Knights at once patrones last words are
letting Deanne know that she could
become even stronger than her some
Knights managed to escape and create a
false story where they blamed the Anne
for what happened when they're charging
the Anne with the murder of Matrona they
say the end of the giant clan your envy
over Matrona spout drove you to poison
an important ally of the kingdom and to
keep your crime a secret you brutally
murdered 330 of the kingdom's knights
and quote so it was because of this
false story that she got the name
serpents and of envy however if we
recall she was envious of humans when
she learned that they could marry and
she is envious of Elizabeth near the
beginning of the story because of the
way Mellie Otis treats her so envy is a
sin that she truly needs to overcome
over the course of the series anyways
after she is sentenced to death for her
false crimes
Mellie Otis the great sinner comes to
her rescue and takes her under his
charge next let's take a look at Kings
backstory since we already got a preview
of it from the Anne's backstory King was
born around 1300 years ago from the
sacred tree the tree chose him to be the
third fairy King about 700 years before
the main story begins King was a fairy
King with little
interest in humans and caution other
fairies to be careful around them while
his best friend halgrim took a lot of
interest in them and trusted them to a
fault unfortunately though some humans
ended up tricking halgrim and his fairy
friends the human aldrich wanted to take
their wings which can be sold for a lot
of money he killed a bunch of fairies
and despite Elaine's warning King left
her in charge of the fairy forest so
that he could go and save his fairy folk
from the human threat when he showed up
the place looks like a fairy graveyard
and even Kings best friend halbreth
looked dead King was caught off guard by
the eyepatch wearing Aldrich and almost
died a young D an eventual II saved him
but Kings memories were temporarily gone
he no longer knew who he was as we saw
with the aunt's backstory King and E and
ended up spending centuries together and
becoming really close however eventually
hell Bream shows up to destroy the
nearby human village hell Brom thought
that King wasn't alive all this time he
thought that the humans killed Harlequin
his best friend he's been taking revenge
on all humans this whole time and King
the one who was always cautious about
humans is the one who has to stop him
with tears in his eyes he appears to
kill his best friend and then in order
to atone for his sins lets himself get
arrested after erasing Dan's memories
about him King gets charged with the sin
of sloth because he didn't stop the
fairy halgrim instead he went unaware of
the tragedy and let it go on for so long
Meli ODIs is on the same carriage that
takes King to the prison again King
can't really be blamed for not stopping
hell bro because his memories were
erased but he could potentially be
blamed for leaving his kingdom because
he got too emotional when he saw what
was happening to his best friend next we
have Eskin or praise the Sun Eska nor is
actually the youngest sin and was born
40 years ago he was a prince of the
kingdom of Castelli Oh his older brother
was absolutely terrible to him probably
because he took his shine and he was
jealous
one day s Canora sunshine powers awoke
and he broke his older brother's arm s
canoers body transformed into a much
more muscular form and his parents went
from doting on him to viewing him as a
monster his own mother no longer viewed
s.con.res her son and the entire kingdom
set out to kill him Frankenstein style
only one person was nice to him a woman
named Rosa she put him into a barrel and
helped him escape s Canora grew and even
when he helped people they just get
scared of him and treat him like a
monster it was not until Merlin who
looks like Rosa and Mellie Otis met him
that he finally felt like he belongs
somewhere Merlin and Mellie Otis weren't
scared of him at all rather his powers
made him more interesting in their eyes
askin or as we know fell hard for Merlin
and he's loved her ever since that's the
short version but recently in the manga
we got even more information about s
canora's backstory it turns out that s
canora's daytime form was blamed for
destroying a number of villages and
towns even though he was actually trying
to save the people from a monster people
got scared of him and blamed him for
everything and when the holy Knights
tried to restrain Eskin or they got
injured in his daytime form s Kannur
also showed disrespect towards the king
of the onus as a result he was charged
with the greatest sin of all pride and
sentenced to flogging and then hanging
however as always Mele Otis came to the
rescue and took s Kannur under his
charge asked who nor was the final sin
to join the group when asked what his
specialty is by bond whether it's knives
a bow and arrow spying or assassination
nighttime rescue noir responded poetry
writing which was absolutely hilarious
askin or actually tries to escape during
the night after Mel Yoda saves him but
Merlin stops him asking or fears that
his daytime curse will hurt the sins one
day he says he can't control his daytime
form and that he shouldn't have been
born he thinks that Rosa should have
just let him die instead of rescuing him
that one time later when s Kannur
transforms into his daytime form Mele
Oda shows up in order to show s Kannur
that he doesn't have to worry about
hurting them however asking or punches
melio it isn't the bond and runs away
worried that he accidentally killed both
of them
and hating himself for it he wishes that
someone would stop him and take his life
while he uses a mountain as a punching
bag I don't know if there's any manly or
punching bag than that when night falls
Merlin comes to Eskin or Eskin or tells
Merlin that his cursed power is why he's
alone she asks him to join them but he
says that he doesn't deserve to after
killing melio decide lon however
mellowness and bond show up illustrating
to s Kannur that they're fine and not
ghosts Melly Otis lets us Kannur know
that he is not the only
on stir around all the sins are monsters
who are here to repent for their sins
while living life to the fullest what
lets us know that the kingdom of
costello was destroyed 20 years ago by
barbarians and isn't it interesting to
think about how they chased away the
only guy who could have helped them
defeat the barbarians if that ain't
karma I don't know what is anyways
meliodas decides that he'll fight Eskin
or at noon and that will settle things
if Mellie Otis wins escarole will join
the sins and if s kannur wins he can do
as he pleases
full power Mellie Otis is able to
overpower Eskin ores to one mode at this
point we're just interesting information
s Canora shock that he can feel pain in
this form but Mellie Otis tells him that
he can feel pain because he's alive he
can feel pain because Rosa saved him
with her own life he tells him not to be
selfish enough to think that his life is
his own that is probably one of the most
powerful lines and moments in the seven
deadly sins I must say that s Kannur
finally says that he wants to live and
Mellie Otis smiles
Mellie Otis tells us Kannur day doesn't
need to worry anymore because he'll keep
him in check
then s Canora faints and travels to the
world between life and death to visit
the dead Rosa
he thinks Rosa for protecting him and
says that he's going to live this life
that she's saved to the fullest he says
that no matter what tragedy befalls him
or how lonely he gets he will live on
without being ashamed of this life she
gave him she tells him that there's
nothing to be ashamed of and that with
the sins he'll no longer be alone Rosa
reveals that she's been watching s
kannur all along the side story chapter
closes off with Eska noir swearing to
the gods that with the life Rosa gifted
him he will wager it for someone dear to
him just like Rosa did paid forward
style escarole along with being one of
the most epic characters definitely has
one of my favorite backstories as well
he's like Frankenstein's monster but
more epic overpowered and manly luckily
unlike Frankenstein's monster asked nor
found people who would accept him and
that made all the difference
last but definitely not least we have
Mellie Otis's back story
Mellie Otis is the son of the demon king
and three thousand years ago he was the
leader of the ten commandments he was
the commandment of love Mellie Otis was
on track to become the next demon king
it's funny actually despite the fact
that he is our protagonist
then he had a reputation for being
ruthless evil and terrifying and even
the four Archangels of the goddess clan
feared him at some point meliodas sate
belly on the leader of the six nights of
black from the strongest Archangel mile
malleolus was strong enough to make mild
retreat quite the impressive feat
everything changed though when malleolus
met Elizabeth of the goddess clan they
fell in love and Mellie was abandoned
his title as the leader of the Ten
Commandments and His commandments
as a traitor by the entire demon clan
it's like Romeo and Juliet with Opie
goddesses and demons at one point
zelgius confronted Mellie Otis and
Mellie Otis invited him to desert the
demon clan with his lover gelda
however cell just chose loyalty to his
father and even turned on the vampire
clan and sealed geld away when they
became enemies of the demon clan we are
told that Mellie Otis killed two of the
ten commandments at the time probably
because they tried to stop him during
his escape
Mellie Otis leaving the demon clan
created a power imbalance between the
demon clan and the goddess clan and that
led to the holy war so like Helen of
Troy
Elizabeth indirectly started a giant war
by getting Mellie Otis to leave the
demon clan Mellie Otis fought alongside
Elizabeth droll anglex Enya as part of
stigma until the ladder to join the ten
commandments Mellie Otis became friends
with the bond look-alike row at some
point they even bumped fists together
like bottom Mellie Otis to 3,000 years
later and although he knew that Mellie
Otis was a demon ro could tell that he
was a good person even while his fellow
demons thought that he was the worst
scum that ever existed
eventually the Archangel lunar shock
comes up with a plan to lure all of the
demons into one place so he could kill
them he captures tens of thousands of
demons and uses them as bait to draw out
the other demons including moan speed
and derriere II
however Mellie Otis and Elizabeth just
wanted to stop the war so they intervene
but not before lunar shell kills tens of
thousands of kidnapped demons including
Guerrieri sister right before everyone's
eyes lunar shells plan is to destroy any
chance of a peaceful resolution and he
almost succeeds
commandments begin to fight Archangels
and then once meat and dairy Arry become
Endura sacrificing most of their demon
hearts and sanity to beat the Archangels
usually they shouldn't be able to
back to normal but Elizabeth helps to
save them while Mellie Otis protects her
from Lou no show soon after that the
Gophers performed their genjutsu and
Mellie Otis along with everyone else
starts to believe that miles actually is
a little brother esta rosa who somehow
managed to kill the strongest Archangel
mile around this time the demon king and
the supreme deity cursed their children
Mellie Otis and Elizabeth for their
defiance and forbidden love the supreme
deity cursed Mellie Otis with
immortality as his punishment so that he
gets survived every time he dies on its
own that's a pretty crappy punishment I
mean most people will do anything for
immortality but the immortality takes on
a new meaning because of the curse the
demon king places on Elizabeth he curses
Elizabeth with perpetual reincarnation
she is fated to live human lives in
which she always reunites with Mellie
Otis they fall in love and she dies
right before his eyes over and over
again
the current Elizabeth Elizabeth Leonys
is the 107th reincarnation so Mellie
Otis has already watched 107 Elizabeth's
die and he never gets used to it
although we are told that some
Elizabeth's simply died of old age
apparently this is a fate worse than
death for Mellie Otis because he needs
to watch Elizabeth die over and over
again but I feel like the fact that she
comes back makes it less bad than if
Mellie old has simply had to live for
eternity without her but that's just me
about 16 years before the main story
takes place Mellie Otis was with Liz 106
reincarnation of the goddess Elizabeth
she was from the enemy kingdom of Danna
for and she was sentenced to death but
Mellie Otis rescued her they live
together and predictably fell in love
Mellie Otis said that she was the most
important person to him interestingly
enough she was more violent and less shy
than Elizabeth lianas then entered a
commandment fraud Rijn the people of
Dana for broke his seal and fraud Rand
managed to escape he attacked Anna for
and murdered Liz right in front of
Mellie Otis's eyes after Liz dies
melioidosis rage causes his demon powers
to go out of control his power wipes
Tana for off the face of the world but
fraudulent manages to survive so yeah
you could definitely say he earned a
name wrath
after Mellie Otis finds a baby that is
the new reincarnation of the goddess
Elizabeth Sinatra's tries to help but
Mellie Otis warns him not to touch his
woman which probably looks pretty
frickin weird the baby Elizabeth is
adopted by King bar trolley honest and
Milly Otis becomes a holy night of
Leonys so that he can stay close to
Elizabeth at some point King Bartra has
a prophecy about the seven deadly sins
then Merlin and Milly Otis get all
distance together for the purpose of
defeating the ten commandments if they
managed to escape the goddess clans seal
this has become the highest order of
knights in the kingdom they only answer
to King Bartra and the great holy
Knights a tatras then they go on
adventures one of which includes
fighting vampires and seeing cell
justice vampire girlfriend soldiers his
girlfriend gelda is resealed and Mellie
Otis can't help but wish that he was a
better Big Brother to sell dress who was
left to suffer so much on his own around
ten years before the main story takes
place the sins had a mission that
brought them into contact with the
Druids and the former goddess clan
members Jenna ends an area is an area
developed a thing for Mellie Otis but
hey who doesn't love Mellie Otis Mellie
Otis also served as a young girl
founders mentor he trained him
physically and mentally so that he would
grow up to become a strong holy night
eventually Mellie Otis along with the
rest of the sins was framed for zanottis
as death malleolus told the sins to
disperse and regroup later to figure out
the true cause of his death
and everyone obeyed while they were
escaping a young Elizabeth Leonys tries
to help them escape and gets extremely
injured this leads Mellie Otis to
release his rage again
but luckily Merle is there she knocks
him out and seals away a large portion
of his power with the help of the
affirmation druids
according to Merlin if she didn't do it
Leona's would have been completely wiped
off the face of the earth like Danna for
so props to her because even though it
seemed like she was the cause of beli
Allen's destruction it seems like she
did manage to save lianas afterwards
Mellie Otis awoke and met Hawk Hawk
reminded him of his former bird
companion Wanda the two became good
friends and decided to open up a bar on
Hawkes mama's back since Mellie Otis
could no longer work as a knight Mellie
Otis sold his sacred treasure in order
to fund his startup business Hawk made
for a great business partner whose
specialty was leftover disposal and that
pretty much covers everyone's backstory
up to the beginning of the series this
video took a lot more time than my usual
videos so I really hope you got value
from it drop a like if you did enjoy it
and
know what sends back story is your
favorite in the description for more
videos like this one make sure to
subscribe and bring that notification
Bell so you get notified when brand new
some releases videos drop we have a
seven deadly sins playlist approaching
100 videos so it's safe to say that
you'll never run out of seven deadly
sins greatness especially since we're
always adding to the playlist for even
more seven deadly sins content and
crucial updates on the new seasons you
can follow us on twitter and instagram
at anime uproar of the day i dropped
this video i will have a tournament
bracket through the anime uproar
instagram story function where you will
be able to vote for which back story
passes to the next round until there's
only one left so make sure to head over
to instagram if you want your vote to
count because stories only last for 24
hours i will do more of these tournament
brackets in the future so make sure
you're following us link to our
instagram can be found in the
description and I'll probably do a pin
comment as well a big thank you goes out
to our patrons over on patreon who help
make videos like this one possible I
especially want to thank our pro here to
your patrons the one and only gilgamesh
nothing about a fan Jason Wilson King
cell just angel Cruz Steelers poet Pablo
atropos Wraith fitty dalla beat at
Karachi and Anatole Cassatt's key DJ
methanol and Matteo and are the one tier
patrons the ones who stand atop all
clans Steven and Radha al-hola Gotham
Maddy Mac 239 makoto-kun and you boys
set if you enjoy our work you can
support Barbara by going over to
patreon.com slash anime uproar and
becoming a patron today for as little as
one dollar if you do so you'll gain name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patient only discord
so check out patreon.com in the
description if you're interested you can
also now join the YouTube channel and
support more content that way if you
prefer you'll get the same great
benefits no matter which way you choose
to support us and until next time see
you space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]